fabienne larouche bonsoir au sort pas pu
vous l'avez vous l'avez appris quand
vous est ce que c'est le dieu n'en peut
plus j'applique williams n 2 a dit
fabienne faut qu'on arrête non en fait
c'est depuis mois de septembre qu'on a
commencé à parler de ça partagez ce le
cas ni michelle et moi et puis à un
moment donné j la décision était prise
autour du mois d'octobre et puis je
téléphonais un raid au canada pour leur
disait voici il va arriver ce c'est la
dernière année de type mig 31 mai on a
voulu l'annoncer aujourd'hui par
courtoisie part je dirais aussi un été
et reconnaissance envers les
téléspectateurs comme vous disiez en un
million et demi avec nous ou coûte à
tous les soirs 7,4 soir semaine 120 fois
par année donc pour toi que le 21 avril
comme sont là c'est fini c'est la fin
des districts a donc tout le monde doit
pouvoir un peu faire son aux soldes et
parce que quand on apprend que c'est la
fin d'une série on a oui à d'ailleurs
fermé en même temps on a du plaisir est
ce encore cinquante cinq épisodes à
écouter et puis la fin va être
magnifique est ce que oui on imagine les
tomates la da est ce que vous avez
imaginé un scénario où d'autres joueurs
que le dionne plus continuer de 5,31 où
c'est impossible dans votre esprit est
possible d'abord janota moi même mais
l'udc a été extraordinaires de courage
de persévérance bien sûr mais de talent
pire son propre langage et ça ça se ça
peut poser immigrés comme ça c'est un
autre auteur ou quelqu'un dont je crois
pas en fait district sainte est
incroyable une aventure incroyable pour
lui que michel les mois mais aussi c'est
le cas et est supporté par un groupe
d'acteurs hyper doué une équipe
technique dédié c'est quand tout le
monde tout le monde a décidé de
travailler là dessus puis de le faire
même après ça ça donne ça mais je pense
que l'udc c'est aussi une vie d'ascète
pour un auteur je n'ai vécu pendant 20
ans c'est tout de grands plaisait mais
aussi de grandes privations et le look
avec avec le décès de jean marc vale et
on s'est tous dit ok c'est lui à 61 61
ans luc moi j'en ai 60 ans on se dit ok
faut peut-être penser à autre chose pu
aussi sinon c'est notre métier nous les
hauteurs de créer des univers où des
histoires naissent vivent et se termine
alors voilà
oui est ce que oui bah on parlait d'une
hebdomadaire
dpcp adepte du canada est ce que est ce
que c'est il ya eu un miracle qui est
arrivé jeudi est un phénomène télévisuel
qui est difficile à reproduire parce que
je m'y inscrire une autre quotidien est
ce que vous allez vous embarquez l'enjeu
notre quotidien dès l'an prochain
c'est une très très bonne question vous
savez je pense vais miser sur tout être
a dû à passer flambeau après six ans a
emmené des doutes en fait des
producteurs des créateurs une job de
consultant ces deux quotidiens ne
faudrait pas que la bonne affaire c'est
vrai il ya autant patrice où il faut
passer le flambeau ok donc il repose
vous ne vous n'allez pas produire une
autre qu'une hausse quotidienne pour
radio canada l'an prochain
ouais
nous ne resterons pas je ne peux pas
vous êtes nord parce que c'est pas
classe et
une patrice aussi c'était compliqué
d'arrêter trequesser cette zone ça c'est
dit c'est fait quand même 26 ans je lui
disais tu es fab c'est un cri pour nos
produits vins et tente de virginie
grande vie on a fait six ans de district
c'était un bonus qu'est ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors patrice
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
tout chercher des cadeaux a
décidé de recréer à l'infini des
quotidiennes qui marchent à ce point
vous dites je pas une machine non plus
c'est pas simple quand charlotte se sait
c'est une tempête parfaite je peux dire
c'est arrivé à un auteur vraiment doué
avec une gamme d'acteurs vraiment doué
avec une équipe douée avec des
producteurs aussi que ça peut faire une
belle job et pilot tout à coup de pouce
avec un diffuseur paupières radio canada
était d'un succès là dedans d'une aide
alors c'est ça maintenant
on verra c'est tout ce qu'on me dise que
je vous dise que je vous ai dit c'est
que je pourrais donner quand c'est le
temps de briser way pour aller tenir sur
trois les aidants mais on attendait de
lui
je vais attendre et des dents je dois
vous laisser parce que rappelé une météo
bien et annonce du froid mais fabien
merci c'est un plaisir vous revenir nous
parler quand vous voulez salut au revoir